come on you get the show on the road you
got a bunch of stuff to talk about
you don't love me right if you really
love me
give me the thing that I really crave
which is a divorce I was super excited
to work with you because I've been such
a fan of yours and then you came in you
just blew everybody away take off your
glasses so you're trying to divorce me
on acid you're not thinking straight
that's why I'm thinking straight
this isn't all Peggy Newman I'm a pi but
I'm working up a case is that a lady's
finger
it's nice to do something where there's
so much history right at the onset this
just sounds like another one of those
crazy things you're trying between
rehabs come on I'm like Mary Tyler Moore
on methadone
Peggy to me is a real Hustler but you
are the only person who out hustles her
there she is are you kidding me
but Danny is a schemer but he really
believes in this new spiritual path I've
got an email list of men who are looking
for a safe place to practice Qigong and
early in the story and he wants his
woman back he wants his wife back look
at you I know you're a Phoenix
baby he hasn't decided that they're
divorced yet I'm the man I'm gonna take
care of things it'll be good for us in
the end you're such a liar I
only lied so we could be together when I
got out
can I have a coffee and a apple pie and
a prime rib to go and give this
the check
they both have these wedding bands
tattooed to their fingers but hers has
been covered with an X you know Peg I
choose to focus on the good times not
the bad
ly authentic too that's the thing like
more than anything about this the best
parts of them are aligned and the worst
parts of them are aligned maybe I've
been a little harder on you I just still
want to give you the benefit of the
doubt you know I am trying thank you for
seeing that yeah
um can I call you back
where would you see Peggy and Denny 10
years from now
if they're both alive